je vous appelez juste pour savoir si
votre mariage de samedi était maintenu
dernier week end et dernier mariage
avant les nouvelles mesures dans ce
salon de coiffure
on craint une annulation à la dernière
minute je ne sais pas ce qu'elle compte
faire si elle maintient son mariage
aussi elle pas le des commandes et comme
beaucoup ont fait jusqu'à présent
voilà et j'en ai encore le 3 octobre le
10 octobre
la cliente maintient finalement son
mariage
80 personnes invitées et le doute
jusqu'à la veille de la célébration
l'anxiété
c'est pourquoi beaucoup reporte mariages
séminaires ou remise des diplômes
l'e commerce spécialisé dans
l'événementiel pâtissent de ces
désistements enchaîne ce traiteur a
perdu près de 100000 euros depuis le
début des mesures
la journée de commandes était rempli
tous les tableaux étaient remplis pour
une journée donc vous rendez bien compte
la différence
on n'a que quelques commandes cinq ou
six commandes alors qu autrement on
pourra avoir grandi 40 commandes subir
la crise sanitaire
en attendant qu'elle passe la préfecture
de côte-d'or a organisé une réunion de
crise jeudi pour décider des modalités
d'application